stop the ratting stop ratting out all
these idiots that ran in the [ __ ]
the capital they're idiots some of them
did
commit crimes a lot of them didn't they
were just standing there being morons
i told you this sobering up from the q
and on wasn't gonna go well
who told you that i said that
i've been on record going they're not
gonna take it well
when they find out that this shit's not
really gonna work out the way they want
it to
imagine you thought you were saving the
children and then you find out you know
you're not that no one's being saved
and you're wrong and the people you've
invested
your [ __ ] time into in some cases
your money
the people you had faith in have sold
you down the river like trump did
when he went up and and you know
correctly he was like what the [ __ ]
can't do this after encouraging them and
egging them on
saying they were great people they went
out and went well wait a minute
but this is what happens
this is a a tough pill for those people
to swallow
but you don't need to rat on everybody
in that crowd
come on i didn't even rat on the airbnb
who tried to destroy my life
because we simply wanted to have a meal
in their drug den
in joshua tree i didn't even drop a dime
on
them because i am against
ratting i
you know just let it go also why do you
want to do your
someone else's job for them why do you
want to do
someone else's job that's the cops
job let the cops figure out who stole
nancy pelosi's pen
you don't have to go into citizen
detective mode
and figure out who is responsible
i mean for doing whatever the hell they
did
supposedly smearing [ __ ] is that true
yeah yeah they took shits in the
bathrooms and
tracked it all over the capitol building
yeah yeah yeah
they're doing what they're accusing the
the cues accusing the
senators are doing these people like how
do you like him
but you don't have to go out there and
and you know where in the world is
carmen san diego where in the world is
you know i don't know
the dude with the horns or whatever
these people are going to get found out
you don't have to be an online sleuth
these people are going to get found out
the cops are going to arrest them this
is what's going to happen but it's so
funny schizophrenic everything is like
now
now everybody is like cops are heroes
these police are heroes the capitol
police are heroes
you see those cops they're heroes you
see the black cop
who's who's all the white people yelling
at him he's a hero
however the black cop where the white
and black mixed race crowd was yelling
at him with the blm protest
that guy's a uh part of the problem but
now that guy's a hero
you see so nobody has any values nothing
matters
truly nothing matters no one really
cares the cops are heroes now
and protesting is bad just being out of
protest is bad
and it should bar you from ever being
employed again ever
no one should work ever again you should
lose your job
as an apprentice at the tattoo parlor
these people that have high level jobs
but they work at like call centers
there's some poor guy some schmuck who's
gotten sucked into a q anon cult
because he can't afford any other type
of cult
he's [ __ ] you know spent six months
thinks he's hunting pedophiles on 4chan
then he [ __ ] goes to meet up with his
friends all of a sudden he gets
caught up in a moment and he's in the
[ __ ] chamber
of you know congress yeah i mean it's a
bad choice
it's probably gonna [ __ ] him from doing
certain things let that schmuck
i get if he's charged with a crime he's
charged with a crime whatever
you know if you got caught you got
caught but don't you go and i mean
let the guy go back to the call center
job
this isn't the cfo of [ __ ] goldman
sachs running around there
these people's lives are not great
that's why they're there with
a helmet on nobody has a really good
life is in the congress with a helmet on
i'm telling you these people have mental
problems
most of them it's the blm people a lot
of them the hardcore
i'm talking about you know the 300-pound
woman with purple hair
the people that are screaming and going
nuts and
my friends 80-year-old uncle's in a car
and they go up to the car they're like
say black lives matter
say it the people that are like
harassing the elderly
they have mental problems as well it's
not just like
you have a political difference with
these people they're extremists
that ideology comes from being mentally
unwell
being socially unwell
these are anti-social personality
disorders they should be studied
not listened to not retweeted
they should be studied
but you know i i just can't get involved
with the ratting
these people really thought this
presidency was going to end a different
way and i mean you know unfortunately
i was ringing the bell for them telling
them this is not the way it's going to
work
you know it's like the movie clifford
the great movie clifford starring in one
of my favorites charles grodin and then
martin short
clifford with mary steenburgen clifford
was great because clifford wanted to go
to dinosaur world
and uh you know his uncle martin kept uh
running into problems he was unable to
take him to dinosaur world
well and then he of course went insane
and
um his uncle martin was building a model
of the
la transportation system and then
clifford blew it up sorry spoiler alert
spoiler alert and that is how people
reacted when they found out they
couldn't go to dinosaur world that they
weren't going to be personally arresting
barack and michelle obama
and putting them in guantanamo bay they
thought they were going to be marching
down [ __ ] beverly boulevard and they
were going to go up into the hills to
chrissy teigen's house
and take her out and arrest her and then
i guess steal her cookware line and
cook with it or i don't know but they
really thought this was was going to
happen and alan degeneres was gonna be
going to jail
none of this was true all this was
[ __ ] all of this was like
you know a larping [ __ ] just
troll game that these people fell for
because they're terribly unsophisticated
and because the country is so
[ __ ] up and so many of the monsters
are real
that these people found out about it and
their hand their brains melted they had
no idea
when they found out about the epsteins
and the this and that and how [ __ ] up
things are
automatically overnight they started
they got an overflow of information and
they were manipulated by people
like steve bannon and these other people
that didn't give a [ __ ] about them and
just
they thought we're gonna get their votes
and let them believe whatever we want
them to believe and it really
i don't know how many of the people in
the capital were hardcore q
people but i got to imagine it's a few
i gotta imagine some of them found their
way in there
wasn't the guy that i we just did that
sketch he was the q and on shaman
yeah the q and on shaman he goes i see
different uh
levels of uh you know
that was just pedophiles this is him
this guy yeah yeah there he is
jake and jelly i think his name is or
and you know you got people there with
neo-nazi flags and everything like that
but here's the other thing folks and
this is like an uncomfortable thing
nobody really wants to talk about this
nobody really wants to admit this
you're not going to be able to arrest or
a shame every nazi you're going to have
to deal with certain nazis you know if
you want a tattoo
you might have to deal with the nazi
unknowingly this is what it is you don't
think i
you don't think i have to deal with
hardcore uh
you know anarcho communist of course
what if i want ice cream in portland
i can't scoop it myself i got to deal
with one of these militant dikes i don't
care
i don't want them to lose their job i
just walk in i go yeah
punch nazis and rocky road or whatever i
want that day
and this [ __ ] scoops it up and it's we
move on
i don't give a [ __ ] i don't i don't go
oh this [ __ ] wants to destroy
anything good about what i think this
country means
let's get rid of her i don't care that
if she heard my comedy she'd probably
want me in a cage i just moved the [ __ ]
on
get your [ __ ] ice cream and go get
your tattoo and go
why are we gonna arrest everybody people
oh i don't who cares what people believe
yes if you run into the capitol yes
you're gonna get arrested it's what it
is
i mean i don't know what to tell you you
know if you do something crazy in the
blm protest you burn down somebody's
small business
yeah you're gonna be arrested you're
destroying property like
you know what are you gonna do but if
you're just being an
idiot i don't know what's the punishment
for that you're probably not doing that
great you know so i don't know i just
i think this is this i don't know what
happened when everybody's like we gotta
get we gotta get rid of all these
everybody we disagree with they can't
they can't have shitty jobs
these people aren't really raking it in
here
you know these people aren't doing well
for the most part they're living off
money they've inherited
they they have some type of stipend
they're living in some type of communal
how i don't know what the [ __ ] they're
doing
but i mean i'm sure that i deal profes i
deal professionally
with people i disagree with all the time
about many different things
all the time about many many different
things
you know i i i would never expect
i have a personal trainer who i disagree
with about many things
because he was like he's always like
what are you eating what are you doing
and i'm like
i think it's more important for him to
start looking into cue
and to discover the truth for himself
but he's very like
about me and everything i'm doing and
i'm like that's not that important
when you look at all the children have
you saved all of the children yet
no well then how about you go and state
have you saved any of them
no why well i haven't found the
underground tunnels
anyway what did you have for breakfast
keep looking for the tunnels
there's you see there's we're having a
divergence of opinion we're unable to
serve each other
in in the way that we need to i have
professional disagreement all the time
and i deal with people and i make the
best of it because i'm a [ __ ] adult
i don't care if the dental hygienist
believes in ghosts it doesn't matter to
me if the [ __ ] cleaning my teeth went
to the [ __ ]
area 51 roswell convention and [ __ ]
dressed her dressed like a gray alien
and jumped around on dmt
as long as she's sober when she's
[ __ ] cleaning my teeth
i don't know what this [ __ ] thinks
about i don't want to know
i don't want to know i got enough
problem thoughts in my own goddamn head
to worry about what other people are
doing okay so all these people that are
just
ratting people out oh duh you know don't
give these people any of your money a
you know nazi tattoo or whatever it's
like i don't know don't get a tattoo
they're stupid
tattoos are stupid they are
i'm sorry i know many of you have them
and you love them and everyone has one
now
why don't you be the person that doesn't
get one how about you be the badass that
doesn't get a tattoo
and then you won't worry if your money's
not going to yeah let your dead dog or
your dead grandfather
let them lie you don't need them on your
bicep
let them lie okay
i deal with [ __ ] militant communist
dykes
all the [ __ ] time they're in every
ice cream parlor ever
and i loved coffee at one time they were
in all the coffee shops
black black antifa in the coffee shop if
i want a lemon loaf
i got to deal with black block it is
what it is
and those dykes got a thick loaf and
they make a good espresso
you just go in and you [ __ ] mix it up
with them you act like they actually
[ __ ] punch nazis [ __ ] trump
yeah you know smashed a patriarchy you
know can i get a scone
and earl grey with honey you know just
do what you got to do
so if you're getting it if you're going
to tattoo a nazi tattoo you get in there
i go hey how are you
all right so anyway just i want to clean
this up
yeah just put 1987 there yeah yeah yeah
that's you're my birth all right hi
hitler all right let's do this
just [ __ ] fit in so the whole point
of the country is fit in